for better for worse people
should get to know what
happened
after the fall of his business Empire
Sam bankman freed once seen as the
Golden Boy of crypto is about to go on
trial he is accused of basically lying
to his customers lying to his investors
and lying to lenders about what FTX was
doing with customer funds on October 3rd
bankman Freed's trial on charges that he
defrauded customers of billions of
dollars will begin in a New York federal
court he has pleaded not guilty to all
criminal charges here's what you need to
know about the case and the man on trial
[Music]
at 30 years old in 2022 Sam bankman
freed had founded two successful
companies a trading firm called Alameda
research he started in 2017 and a 32
billion dollar cryptocurrency exchange
called FTX that came two years later FTX
and Alameda research were run by an
inner circle of Sam and his closest
friends and colleagues Caroline Ellison
who was the CEO of Alameda research Gary
Wang who was a co-founder of FTX and
responsible for much of its technology
and nishad Singh who was the director of
engineering at FTX the upper management
all lived together in a luxury pep house
in the Bahamas that cost 30 million
dollars bankman freed was also a
familiar face in the political scene on
Capitol Hill in February 2022 he
testified at a senate hearing where he
encouraged better regulation of
cryptocurrency markets it is the
patchwork of Regulation that there is
simultaneously too many
um sort of cooks in the kitchen and yet
not enough oversight bankman freed
personally made 40 million dollars in
donations ahead of the 2022 midterm
elections at one point he was estimated
to have a net worth of 15.6 billion
dollars he was one of the biggest
richest and most successful people in
crypto until last year when everything
collapsed in November 2022 a report from
crypto website coindesk revealed that
most of alameda's assets were in ftx's
tokens setting off a run but FTX wasn't
able to meet the billions of dollars of
withdrawals bankman freed stepped down
as CEO and shortly after FTX filed for
bankruptcy
in traditional Finance Regulators
require brokerages to segregate customer
funds from any Capital they use for
trading
cryptocurrency is still considered the
wild west where the rules are murkier
this is one of the biggest Financial
frauds in American history
[Music]
bankman freed was arrested in
mid-December in the Bahamas after the
U.S filed criminal charges including
wire fraud and conspiracy to commit
money laundering prosecutors are saying
that he stole money from FTX customers
to use for various purposes including
campaign donations and charitable causes
when that money should have been safe
and secure at FTX
than a year later he
is a jury and his former Inner Circle
Caroline Ellison Gary Wang and nishad
Singh all three have pleaded guilty to
fraud charges and are expected to
testify against bankman freed
Caroline's testimony will probably be
very important in this trial because she
was the head of Alameda research and she
would have been closer to the actual
trading strategies and Alameda
Investments than Sam was so she would be
in a position to say yes we took this
money and used it for these purposes and
knew that we were doing it and here this
is what was Sam's role in that and
bankman freed could take the stand
himself Sam is no ordinary defendant
after the collapse of FTX he gave a
whole lot of interviews tweeted started
a sub stack and tried to defend himself
publicly so he might be inclined to try
and testify in his own defense in an
interview with the journal last December
bankman freed said he bore
responsibility for the company's
collapse but did not knowingly commit
any fraud
I did
I think I I you know tried to commit
fraud anywhere here I was trying to do
the best I could obviously that wasn't
nearly as good as I thought it was
bankman freed could face up to decades
in prison if he's found guilty and he
has a trial for additional conspiracy in
fraud charges tentatively scheduled for
March 2024. the Securities and Exchange
Commission and commodity Futures Trading
commission also have pending civil suits
against bankman freed I think people in
the crypto industry now want to sort of
say okay that happened but we're moving
on it will also be a landmark move for
prosecutors in the government as they
try to regulate and control crypto
they'll be able to say look if you run a
big fraudulent Enterprise we will come
after you and put you in jail
[Music]
foreign